vous avez été arrêté par la police
je n'ai pas le permis sur moi ils vont
me arrêter Rudy Joseph est un militant
engagé au sein d'un groupe de défense
des droits des Haïtiens il vit en
République Dominicaine en toute légalité
depuis 18 ans
que je dois un appel à mon avocat et
c'est ce qui vous a permis d'éviter
d'être expulsé oui dans ce quartier de
Saint-Domingue les commerçants sont
presque tous d'origine haïtienne
ils sont souvent témoins ou victimes
d'arrestation effectuées par la police
de l'immigration
ici pour avoir accès à une bouteille
d'eau un haïtien doit travailler dur
[Musique]
officiel ont dénombré plus d'un demi
million de résidents d'origine haïtienne
dans le pays la grande majorité vivant
dans la capitale la population totale du
pays et de 11 millions
certains résidents dominicains craignent
maintenant une invasion haïtienne comme
celle qui s'était produite au 19e siècle
moi dans le passé
ce député de l'opposition n'hésite pas à
accuser le gouvernement d'hypocrisie
dans sa gestion de l'immigration
haïtienne la majorité des Haïtiens et
non pas de papier en règle ici parce que
l'État dominicain le gouvernement
mais des barrières
en février dernier le président de la
République Dominicaine Louis Sabine Ader
a lancé en grande pompe la construction
d'un mur de 160 km de long le long de la
frontière de son pays avec Haïti
ce projet controversé doit selon le
président aidé à contrôler l'immigration
au clandestine et le crime
[Musique]
ironiquement comme dans la plupart des
chantiers de construction dominicains ce
sont en bonne partie des Haïtiens
illégaux qui travaillent
et parce que
j'ai besoin d'argent
une fois achevé le mur sera haut de 4
mètres il comptera selon l'armée 70
tours de surveillance et de contrôle
[Musique]
la communauté internationale dénonce
depuis quelques semaines l'attitude
agressive des autorités envers les
migrants haïtiens
il n'y a qu'une façon de faire bouger
les choses en faveur d'une
régularisation du statut des illigos
c'est alerter l'opinion publique selon
ses spécialistes c'est pas une bonne
chose que le pays reste comme un objet
d'attention de la presse internationale
des organismes de droits humains et
c'est pas une bonne chose pour le
tourisme le pays inspire à continuer à
accueillir c'est pas un quartier qui
cuisine la majorité des Haïtiens non
la santé économique de la République
Dominicaine dépend à la fois de sa
réputation internationale et de sa main
d'oeuvre iciienne c'est rien ne change
elle risque de perdre les deux
[Musique]